je m'appelle mamadou sylla
j'ai 36 ans et je suis le fondateur de
tamba la première marque de plats
cuisinés aux saveurs africaines
[Musique]
tamba est une entreprise familiale
agroalimentaire qui est spécialisée dans
la fabrication et distribution de plats
cuisinés aux saveurs africaines en
grandes surfaces en france et nos places
sont élaborés par le chef africaine
international qui est connu sous le nom
de chez 30e l'entreprise a été créée en
2017 et nous avons lancé les plats
cuisinés en octobre 2019 lorsque j'étais
vendeur concessionnaires automobiles
j'allais donc pendant la pause déjeuner
avec mes collègues en grandes surfaces
pour pour acheter le déjeuner j'avais du
mal à retrouver ce que je voulais c'est
là que m'est venue l'idée de retrouver
les papas mamans comme je suis très
attachée à la diversité
pour moi cette proposition elle avait
vraiment du sens aujourd'hui on a la
chance d'être dans de grandes enseignes
et on a aussi notre site internet sur
lequel on peut commander qu'ils puissent
tombe à point comme on a été vainqueur
dé snacking d'or dont qui récompense en
fait tout ce qui est ce making
innovation snacking on était sûr sur
sept magasins juste avant le confinement
et à la sortie du conflit monde donc on
est passé à 70 magasins puisqu'on avait
travaillé pendant toute cette période là
c'est ce qui nous a poussés justement
aujourd'hui à recruter
notre objectif à court terme c'est
d'être leader sur le marché des plats
cuisinés en france et à long terme dans
le monde
[Musique]